David, do we really care whether or
not the autonomous vehicle thinks and
acts the way we do?
>> I guess, now that you mention it,
as long as the vehicle gets me to
my destination and doesn't run over
anything on the way, I really don't
care if it does think the way I do.
And if you look at the way I drive, I
really hope it doesn't act the way I do.
>> So the autonomous vehicle may really
belong to the acting rationally side
of the spectrum.
At the same time,
looking at the way humans write
might help us design a robot.
And looking at the robot design might
help us reflect on human cognition.
This is one of the patterns
of knowledge-based data.